electoral commission of the
self-proclaimed donetsk people's
republic said alexander sacharshenko was
the clear winner
this after a campaign marked by
extravagant promises
sarcasenko said pensioners would receive
a stipend that would allow them to go on
safaris
in luhansk rebel leader igor plagnitsky
was said to have cruised to victory the
electoral commission chairman had a
defiant
kiev needs message accept the idea that
donbass is no longer a part of ukraine
it's self-evident
you can disagree with this but you can't
argue with it
speaking with dw the chairman rejected
international criticism saying ukraine's
government represents the interests of
the international community not its
people
ukrainian president petro poroshenko
called the election illegal so did
germany's foreign minister frankfalter
steinmeier traveling in asia he
criticized russia's decision to give its
backing to the elections
we will hold russia to its statements
vladimir putin recently reiterated that
he is for ukrainian unity and that
russia won't question that unity
many here in donetsk are weary of war
they just want peace
of course both sides should hold talks
there's no other way nothing can be
achieved through war
however the russian military continues
to be a common sight at the ukrainian
border along with long convoys said to
contain food supplies for rebel-held
regions